who was on the album any features yeah
we definitely got a lot of features on
there we got over six features probably
for me I got Asian duel oh my God shy K
Dougie b c blue
I got the 41 kids it's a lot of features
on there and especially like New York
oriented because I feel like
as New York we always gonna stand out
after that they put me a lot of station
for me because a lot of States doing
their thing but when you talk about New
York the drill scene is so impeccable
because you got the people from
different size that's doing drill like r
b Alicia Keys everybody that's doing
drill Kanye West so I feel like me going
back to New York and
circling to do songs with these people
and show that we still
yeah how crazy is it to hear like Alicia
Keys singing over a drill beat like that
shit's kind of crazy right yeah about a
day like the more new artist says the
more is new sign for the drill genre
it's always going to grow It's Gonna
Last too would you consider Fabio to
kind of be like the like one of the
Godfathers of this New York drill [ __ ]
because I feel like he was kind of one
of the first guy even before Pop I feel
like he kind of was the guy who like
nationally was making noise I mean
correct me if I'm wrong yeah I'll give
him his flowers bro he's definitely put
on for for a lot of people for me
especially in New York because he did a
lot of features you are so
I'm definitely give me flowers for that